all right a franchise that should have
been extinct and has now come back i'll
give it that the parallels between the
subject matter in this movie and the
franchise and the fact the franchises
always being resurrected should have
been left in the past is kind of
profound probably unintentionally so but
profound anyhow let's talk about it
[Music]
so jurassic world dominion is the third
jurassic world movie or the sixth
jurassic movie depending on how you want
to look at it jurassic park and jurassic
world is kind of like lord of the rings
in the hobbit you can see them as two
trilogies in and of themselves you can
see this one six part saga funny enough
with the jurassic movies though there is
a consistent diminishing of quality as
it goes on but in jurassic world
dominion it's essentially two movies
been fused into one i actually looked up
is this directed by two different people
because there are moments where the shot
is kind of brilliant and the action
sequence is framed up it's pretty
intense and other shots where it's just
choppy as [ __ ] i'm like this is two
different people also the plot itself is
two different plots fused into one movie
on one hand you have the old band
getting back together ian malcolm alan
grant ellie sattler and dogson is
working with the you know the rival
company of injen and he's doing very
nefarious things a super rich big
organization amassing wealth off of a
global epidemic we've never seen that
before not in our world
anu anyhow so you have the old man gets
back together to try to find dirt on
that organization but also what do you
do with bryce dallas howard chris pratt
and the clone girl from the previous
movie she gets kidnapped so now they got
to go after her so you see how it feels
like two different movies though they
both do tie into the same organization i
feel like in the jurassic park movies
there was a concept where it's it's
essentially executed like a disaster
movie i mean the first jurassic park
movie is a few different genres went
splat and fused together and we're
talking as 10 out of 10 for every genre
it hits it's a masterpiece and it's a
complete and total classic but they had
the concept of
executing it like a disaster movie but
when the disaster becomes normalized
that's when jurassic park dies and in
the jurassic world movies will the
disasters become normalized it's no
longer oh if dinosaurs get out there
there's a super scary thing we can't let
that happen we gotta escape the
dinosaurs well now in this world there's
dinosaur black markets and well
dinosaurs are just out there they're
coexisting with people they're
coexisting with nature as we know it
these two worlds been fused together
it's just kind of people are just
rolling with it imagine the movie san
andreas i'm picking a disaster movie at
random out of my head san andreas it is
let's say san andreas got a sequel but
it wasn't a disaster movie anymore it
was a kidnapping movie and it's just
people navigating this messed up
coastline that happened in the previous
movie it's just it changes the dynamic
which is essentially me saying jurassic
world dominion it's a kidnapping movie
where the parents got to get the
kidnapped kid back oh side note there
are dinosaurs in that world that adds a
complication and now we're navigating
this inferior and far more boring
version of the jurassic park world i
will say this there were moments of
tension that actually did land with me
in this movie i mean it comes from a
shitty part of the real world or as real
as twitter can make it it's the backlash
that chris pratt gets from
his religious beliefs i guess i'm not on
twitter that's how it came across to me
but the point is in terms of twitter
hollywood chris pratt's religious
beliefs not really what they did all
this is to say when chris pratt was
running from dinosaurs i was like is
this the moment they kill him off is
this some i don't know so that actually
led to some tension in this movie i
never knew if he was going to live and
that was it was surprising not every day
i can watch a dinosaur chase a lead and
not know if the lead's going to make it
uh rest of the movie quite boring but
i'm just going to say it's way too long
because there's two movies wrapped into
one it also like jurassic park three has
hit that grade b mark where it's like
this is just
this is monster movie cheese but the
grade b cheese like all these huge bugs
are on fire and they're flying and they
just remain on fire for the longest time
i'm like how long can you bugs be on
fire and live also how long can your
wings be on fire and function in the end
i'm sure i've seen worse movies that
feel like two movies fused into one
doesn't mean i gave a [ __ ] about this
one it's kind of fun seeing the old band
back together that's kind of the point
of having them in here but in the end
the movie is a forgettable monster movie
that lost anything that made it special
in the first place well actually i gotta
say credit where credit's dude the last
it wasn't called the last act it was
like the last part of the last act
there's some fun dino action in there
they commit to their grade b monster
movie dip shittery but you know some fun
dino stuff too a little too late though
kind of feels like the last mile of a
100 mile trip it's like whoa we just hit
a race track better late than never glad
you woke up and came out to play but
it's kind of weird i'm done at this
point in the end i'm not going to
remember this movie not in t-minus one
day yep already forgot all right so
jurassic world dominion have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know do you
like the other jurassic world movies but
not this one how does it compare to the
other ones i'm asking for science for
data and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more yeah
[ __ ] it punch
[Music]
you